[Music]
hello everyone um thank you for those
who have joined us in person and those
who are online
um today we have leela corman
[Music]
materiality trauma and expressionist
comics artists talk with leela gorman
um
corman is a painter educator and graphic
novel creator her books include
ultrasound
and the short comics collection we all
wish for deadly force she's currently at
work on the graphic novel victory trade
a story about world war ii women's
wrestling and the liberation of
lukenville
camp and his short comics have appeared
in the believer magazine tablet magazine
nautilus and the nib and before i turn
it over to her i will just mention
that next week is veterans day so we
it's an mit holiday and we will not have
a colloquium and then following that on
november 18 we have craig robertson with
information at your fingertips the
filing cabinet and the gender of
information work
finally
history
right so it's going to be fantastic um
and you're texting uh so i hope to see
many of you there that will be uh hybrid
um in person and also horizonte
so without further ado i you leela
coleman
hi
thanks thank you so much for having me
it's really nice to be here in person
with everyone
um i want to go to this filing cabinet
talk
i i think i'm going to have to join
virtually um
okay so uh as
heather mentioned i'm a cartoonist a
painter
i was an illustrator for a long time i
i had a kind of a funny trajectory as an
artist where i started out i grew up
thinking i was going to be a painter
i had a sort of checkered path through
art school where i kept quitting and
discussed and then coming back and
quitting and discussed again and coming
back and finally i decided okay i want
to get paid to draw pictures so i'm
going to major in illustration and i
just put my head down and did that and
that was my job for
a good
15 years solidly i want to say something
like that i was also making comics at
the same time so i started making comics
while i was in art school um living not
too far away from here actually in an
attic in central square
where i
spent an entire winter listening to
diamond galas and trying to make comics
without really
knowing how they were done
um until my housemate begged me to stop
listening to diamond gloss all the time
every day and
no one begged me to stop making comics
which was good
because i kept going
so when i discovered that there were
people making mini comics i that's when
it really clicked for me and i thought
okay this this is how you do it uh i
recognize this art form because
i've been reading scenes for years this
is just comics in xen form
so i started making mini comics and
self-publishing them and that was the
beginning of
my incredibly illustrious career
in
america's favorite gutter art form
no pun intended so
i'm here to talk a little bit about more
recent work though so i wanna i guess
i will start by talking about
my first big graphic novel which was
called ultrasocian which is a yiddish
word kind of
kind of
uh i worked with a
yiddish translator on this book just
kind of informally i just
worked with her meaning i would email
her occasionally and say hey reba what's
a good word for kind of underwear but
not really underwear more like under
things and this was the word that she
gave me
i believe that it is no dialect of
yiddish it is a kind of an academic word
that comes from
the academic teaching of yiddish uh as a
it's not a dead language at all um but
it's not this this word might not be a
living word i'm not sure my mother grew
up speaking english she didn't recognize
it so this book was set uh on the lower
east side of new york city at the turn
of the last century
and
largely concerns the
lives and activities of a pair of twins
named fagna and esther
who are growing up in a tenement
um oh right my screen isn't shared
thank you
um
so you've got a bunch of windows open
which one um well let's go to the
slideshow um
we can go here yeah
thank you
and you know what let's go back to the
book cover
so that the
there we go it's great
thanks
so
i should stress this is a work of
fiction um it's a it's literally a
graphic novel uh
meaning it's a work of literary fiction
in comics form not not autobiographical
which is funny because people have
sometimes asked me if it is and i just
look at them and i say do you see a pair
of twins here and is it 1909
um
the original idea for this book came at
a time when
the discourse around reproductive
rights reproductive freedom was getting
heated and ugly again although i don't
think it's ever not been heated and ugly
in this country
it was in the george w bush years though
and it was starting to get ominous again
so
i was thinking about this and i was
walking to
the 63rd street ymca in manhattan where
i had gone to camp as a little kid i was
going to see the cartoonist kim deutsch
give a talk and i was sitting there and
i suddenly had this image in my head of
the character of fagna
that i drew on a napkin which i really
wish i still had of course that is lost
to time
um
and suddenly all the characters tumbled
out of my head this set of twins their
mother their their traumatized father
from russia
the entire neighborhood that they lived
in and the trajectory of both of these
girls lives
and i spent many years creating this
book so
um
[Music]
i was working in ink here and computer
gray tones so those are not cut half
tones although
i i have spent a lot of time with an
exacto knife and sheets of halftone i
don't do that anymore
um
i would call this kind of my old comic
style
that i i honed when i was making mini
comics
greek mythology came out a lot when i
was working on this book uh so there's a
lot of references to the myth of
persephone
and to the odyssey in this book i'm
purposely not showing a ton of this so
i'm not going to spend a whole lot of
time on this but i'm happy to talk about
this book if people want to once we get
to the end
i am
so
let me not get ahead of myself i
published this book in 2012 and then a
whole
bunch of things happened in my life
and
emerging from that i started making
short autobiographical comics which i
had said i would never do
and yet and yet
i ended up doing them so
pardon me while i fumble around on the
screen just a little bit
i have
only brought the most recent one to show
you i've done quite a few short
autobiographical comics since this uh
since then
but this is a piece that i did last
spring
so i think you have to share do i have
to share a new okay um
actually do like yeah
so
in into november 2011 i delivered just
to my publisher
november 2nd and on november 17 2011 my
daughter died suddenly so
i spent about a year just not being able
to do anything uh and then when i
emerged from that i only wanted to make
comics illustrations seemed very
useless um
i didn't stop being an illustrator
am i sharing now because this
is still popping up okay there we go
you'll have to forgive some of my
technical fumbling uh i'm used to
sharing from my own screen
at home while i'm teaching but not this
many things at once
uh so
i started making short autobiographical
comics as i was kind of emerging from
the the year of trauma after that
and i i started to get very excited
about working with
reportage and research and and
my own
personal experience again that's a place
a lot of us start in comics because it's
a good place to start but
going from there into fiction was really
fun going back was also really great so
this is a piece that i did
last year uh
two years ago i i went to poland for the
first time to visit my grandfather's
hometown
it's kind of a shaggy dog story it's in
this piece but
how do i make this as short as possible
i found out that there's a group of
people in my grandfather's hometown
specifically one guy
mainly who
is obsessed with researching the jewish
history of the town and reconnecting
with all of the living descendants of
the jews of this little tiny town it's
like a two street town in southeastern
poland called
and there's a whole lot of other crazy
stuff attached to all of that but the
upshot of this is that i went to poland
for the dedication of a memorial in the
jewish cemetery of my grandfather's town
and i thought i was going to have this
really heavy really dark time
and instead what happened was i ended up
falling in love with poland uh with
everything about it and now all i can
think about is going back to poland and
making comics about poland
um
that you know i went back and they
stuck a mountain of pierogies in front
of me
they took me to a mass grave where my
great grandparents are and then they
filled me with pierogies
part of what happened was that i
i found out about all of these
connections through a student of mine at
uf
who
said oh have you ever been to poland i
went to this little tiny town called
because there's this guy in my shule
in west palm beach who who grew up there
and it turns out this guy grew up next
door to my grandfather
and was in auschwitz with primo levy and
here he is telling me this whole story
where he's telling me how nobody thought
primo levy was jewish because he didn't
speak yiddish
uh primo levy is one of my favorite
writers so as he's telling me this i'm
just kind of sitting there staring at
him i can't believe i'm hearing this
this is amazing
um
and something i really enjoy doing in my
fiction and my nonfiction is
playing with that line between the
living and the dead the worlds of the
living and the dead
i'm going to start to get more into that
as we move further into this
presentation but this is where it starts
to happen in this story um
the glass lanterns are part of the
tradition for all saints day of bringing
glass lanterns to the cemetery and and
uh paying respect to your dead ancestors
this is a catholic tradition as far as i
know in poland but they did it in the
jewish cemetery anyway so here i'm
imagining that the the spirits of all of
my dead great aunts and
great-grandparents are complaining about
my short skirt and
lack of yiddish language abilities
in the cemetery
so
i want to talk before i get into my
newest project about artistic influences
and
a few other things but i'm going to stop
here for a second and talk about
um
working with comics as a material art
form a little bit too
so
when i started to talk about playing
with the boundary between life and death
and the worlds of the living and the
dead that is where the materiality of
making comics comes in for me i've been
thinking about this a lot in the context
of a lot of art forms drawing and
painting art forms
where does the mark become the work
before i came here i went to the harvard
art museum and i was i was thinking
about this a lot as i was in in the room
full of
abstract expressionist paintings and
related kind of mid-century work
and i i it's
i don't have an answer to that question
i just want that question floating in
space in front of me all the time
i think that there is uh an extreme
physical pleasure in making
marks that become work
right that sometimes that pleasure in in
making the mark itself is the work
and finding that when you're making
something is is exhilarating
so i find it when i am working with
viscosity and color in my comics and i
don't know if this comes across in print
or in a scan uh there's a materiality
and physicality to my work that exists
in the originals that is hard to
translate however sometimes
interestingly it can come through and
i'll i'll explain that when we get to
that page
um
so these questions of materiality and
physicality are they're they're open
ones
they're they're not answered questions
they never should be
i guess also i'm thinking about this a
lot because i teach comics and i and i'm
observing how
many people are working with digital
materials now and i think it's great i
um i love digital comics i think all
those tools are beautiful
um
i personally happen to like to work by
hand and for me there's a there's a
tactility
and a physical experience that is very
important
it's not just one experience it's the
experience of my body as i'm drawing
it's also
it's also what the materials do and the
way they lead you into the story itself
that they they are the work sometimes
all right so
i'll do another screen share
where
are you
oh dear
rudely i can't
find the one i'm looking for which is
this one back here
that okay now
what are you what's
do you see it oh you know i like that
i think it's this one i think it thinks
yeah yeah okay
all right great
that's a mistake that particular slide
shouldn't be in there
so now i want to talk about influences
and i think that this is a really
important thing to think about um
i always get that
line from an early fall single in my
head i'm eternally grateful to my past
influences um
that's from the song how i wrote elastic
man if you're a fan of the fall
and now it's going to be in my head all
night um so when i'm teaching what i
tell my students
is the the
the way to become
a good illustrator a good cartoonist is
to
make sure you're filling yourself with
good material
which is like very obvious but
bears saying anyway so what are what are
you putting in your
i like to use the word nebula i think of
it as kind of a
nebula around you that you're reaching
into and pulling from when you're
working
um
so the first one i want to talk about is
the filmmaker pedro omodovar who
taught me more than anybody else has
about
nonverbal communication in a story with
color
so yesterday when i was putting this
presentation together i actually just
typed um
color in almodovar films into google and
i actually i came up like a lot of
interesting stuff came up
many pieces of writing
a surprising number of uh palettes that
people have created from his different
films
um which of course you can purchase as a
poster or a tote bag or a yoga mat
so
maybe i'll do that at some point
this is a still from the film all about
my mother
which is an amazing amazing movie i just
rewatched that and you know i think
i love
almost all of his films unreservedly but
i think this one might be my favorite
i also want to talk about the influence
of
weimar era
art on my work
specifically the new objectivity
painters
so this is
a print by otto dix i'm going to talk
about autodicks a little bit and i'm not
going to talk about this from an art
history perspective because i'm not
qualified to do that
i really wish i could
but uh
i'm i'm
just a puny aunt staring at the pictures
most of the time and taking them in and
letting them influence me in ways that
i'm not even fully aware of when i'm
working
but in the book i'm about to talk about
auto dix's influence looms very very
large
so
these are drawings and prints that he
created in the immediate aftermath of
the first world war
after serving
in
in the war but also
from observations in in berlin
now this is really small that is the
screen being properly shared because
there's no green edge around it yeah
it's showing the
you know what i'm not even going to
bother with that one because it's too
small but
that would be great yeah let's do that
because i don't want to go back to that
really grotesque image thank
you um
i am incredibly fascinated with these
artists and otto dix of course is only
one he just happens to be one who's
really large over my work and
i'll go down to a painting that i steal
from a lot
this is his uh war triptych
tryptocon de krieg you'll have to excuse
me i have absolutely zero ability to
replicate a german accent so anything i
say any german words i try to say just
gonna sound like an american saying them
this is an incredible painting that i've
never seen in real life but i am
absolutely obsessed with it obviously it
is a painting about trench warfare
in the style of a medieval altarpiece
these legs
in the upper right corner of the center
panel i have a habit of stealing them
and putting them into a lot of my comics
there's almost always a place for them
i think this painting is absolutely
stunning and i i hope to see it in
person one of these days
um
we're not going to talk about 11 rockets
yet
we're going to talk about
we are going to talk about
well you know
oh you know what there's one
that i thought i put in here but it
doesn't seem to be in here because i put
it in this morning that's okay
actually let's talk about eleven rockets
before we talk about seven beauties so
another huge influence is this comic
love in rockets and i really hope that
um that you read it one of these days it
is and to my mind
the best comic ever created in the
english language and i'm being really
specific about that because comics is a
global art form and there's i'm never
going to say what the best comic is i i
you know
i don't believe there's ever a best
anything really except for loving
rockets that's the best comment
uh
especially anything by jaime
so this is a comic created by jaime and
gilbert hernandez and originally their
brother mario
who i think dropped out after the first
issue i'm not sure
they've been doing it since the early
80s and it's
deep and extremely
intertwined storytelling that you kind
of have to start at the beginning with
this is a this is a
jaime hernandez cover
and let's just go up here
and this is the cover of the of
gilbert's book poison river which has
been a massive influence on the kind of
stories that i always wanted to tell
so
i think these were the first comics i
read that that told me you could say
anything in this art form and you could
be very serious
and
talk about
uh dire things talk about
very personal things talk about
interiority
show interiority and also trauma in
comics
if you read only one book by gilbert
hernandez in your life make it this one
it's a bit of an origin story of a
character who shows up all the way
through
the other and other cartoonists who
really taught me
that you could do almost anything in
comics is phoebe lechner
uh and you know what how did you zoom in
did you just
command plus okay
so
phoebe is a cartoonist originally from
san francisco um these are a couple of
pages from her story nightmare on polk
street
in her collection of child's life
i read this i think i don't know i was
like 19 or 20.
and it just blew my mind i've never been
able to stop thinking about it
if you've seen the film diary it's a
diary of a teenage girl oh my god why am
i half blanking on that title
yeah that's the title um that's based on
phoebe's book that's kind of a
combination of prose and comics and
pulls from this story a lot although it
takes the teeth out of it and and the
really severe
longer term part of the story kind of i
felt wasn't really in there although
it's an amazing movie and i recommend it
what actually is going on in this story
is so much more intense
um
and that's that's from the very end of
the story
phoebe started out as a medical
illustrator that's her training so
that's
um
one reason why her work is so
meticulously grotesque
i've only included a few cartoonists
here i could talk all night about
art
in comics and in other art forms that
has been a massive influence on me i
will say i think
i put myself squarely in the tradition
of expressionism and new objectivity
painting and drawing
and
i'm not sure if phoebe
or the hernandez brothers would say that
but i would say they're very
expressionistic and
not concerned with making work that is
cute
or
um
neutral in any way visually or or
or textually
so i'm gonna get a little closer now to
the work that i'm doing now this is a
still from lena workmueller's film seven
beauties
which i highly recommend um
i mean you know i'll also give a content
warning it's it it's full of stuff that
will
upset you
in so many ways it will trigger warning
for everything basically content warning
for everything um
so i've started
i
i come from a family of holocaust
survivors and i tried to get away from
doing work about that time period for a
very long time
and it just kept pulling me back and
pulling me back it's like a vortex i was
thinking again about this in the harvard
art museum today because
so much of the focus there is on
modernism
and
and then there's this shift into the
post-war period in their collections
[Music]
and
because they have a focus on german art
in part of it there's a lot of of german
art from the immediate post-war period
so i was thinking a lot about
wrestling with that
that rupture in the middle of the 20th
century which was not just a rupture if
you're jewish it was the whole planet
world war ii is a massive vast subject
and as soon as you start
researching any of it from any
perspective it it opens up into such a
vast area that you
you either leave it behind forever or
you focus only on that for the rest of
your life it feels very extreme to me to
work with this material
so
i really resisted doing a book that had
any kind of content about the holocaust
at all because it is hard to talk about
in a way that feels new although
i would have actually you know what i
would have said that let me put that in
the past tense i felt that
now i don't
because now i'm seeing the way people
talk about it in cliche and the way
people talk about it in a fresh way and
and you can you can get to the second
this film was made in 1975 and
i was kind of on my knees
with my eyes bugged out of my head from
the very beginning of it
this scene that this is a still from
comes late in the film and it is one of
the most disturbing and perverse things
i have ever seen
i i think
i'll take a little bit of a side here
and aside to say i i came up and trained
in a time when being confrontational
in art was highly valued
in the culture in general in the
subcultures that i came up in in music
in in visual art and comics
uh
and
there were a lot of people who were
trying to make work that was
transgressive so i ended up kind of
coming out on the other side of that
thinking well you know i don't think
most of us who are trying to do
something transgressive are actually
transpressing anything
transgressiveness requires parameters
right
you can't transgress anything if you
don't have any bounds around you
uh so it seemed sort of like
a hopeless target to try to hit
however i have come across several works
of art that i do consider transgressive
and this scene is one of them because it
transgresses the boundaries of what is
usually shown in a film about the
holocaust you're supposed to talk about
there are sort of accepted narratives
that you're supposed to use and i love
that this does not do that
so when i saw this film i thought well
you know if i make anything even half
this good in my life at this intense
i can die happy
um
my feeling is that there is no
no limit to how
how grotesque and how how perverse you
can be when showing the depravity of war
crimes
of of any particular time period in
history
um i am disturbed by attempts to tidy
narratives about the holocaust or any
similar atrocity and tell a clean story
about it because
there's no way to do that without lying
i know that sounds really extreme but
and i understand that information needs
to be categorized in order to be clear
but part of my goal is to keep the story
of the showa as messy as possible
because it was extremely chaotic and
messy and humans are chaotic and messy
there are no heroes
in in the true story of any of this
so i recommend this movie um it's not
only about the holocaust it's also about
probably the dumbest criminal in italy
and parts of it are very funny
um
uh let's see i can't remember if there's
anything else
in this incredibly beautiful and
disturbing slideshow you know what let's
just leave you on an image of penelope
cruz
[Music]
from the film vulvar
from which i also learned a lot about
color no one uses red
like almodovar and it's not always blood
all right so
how are we doing on time
now
okay great so i'm going to talk a little
bit about the work i'm doing now
and then i think q a i'm talking
so
now i'm working on a book called victory
parade
and i will share my screen momentarily
oh okay this is sharing this okay great
all right so now i'm working on this
book that is set during the second world
war partially in brooklyn and partially
at the liberation of buchenwald
but there's a little bit of a flashback
to berlin in the 1930s and that's what
this page is from
um
this book is
partially about women working in the
brooklyn navy yard
and
there's a subplot about women's
wrestling that has become sort of not
the a plot i would say but as important
if not more important to me than the
navy yard possibly because i like
drawing wrestlers more than i like
drawing shipyards
i'm really a figurative artist and so
every every single time i
pitch and and and land a book about new
york city then i curse myself because i
realize oh no that means i have to draw
architecture and cars
very few people like drawing cars
so here um i'll zoom in a little bit
i just copied an auto dick's painting
from a postcard in that bottom panel
that is a copy of a painting called the
scat players
but i did sneak in something extra
that's not in the original which is the
woman pouring the alcohol
she's a callback to
the
the war widow sex workers that autodicks
painted frequently
i gotta say it's really fun copying your
favorite painter i recommend trying it
because you get inside of the work it's
like if you're a musician and you're
covering a song it's you you get inside
and you get to take it apart with a
little screwdriver
and and then put it back together and
see how they did it
i did this so literally i had the
postcard of the painting taped to my
desk and i did this with a double zero
round
and a one and a zero also it wasn't all
double zero
i like to work with really tiny brushes
now
um another huge influence on me is the
1930s and 40s choreographer busby
berkeley
um
have any of you seen a buzzy berkeley
film ever
a couple yeah okay so he was a
he was an iconic choreographer in film
during the depression and the second
world war
and when you watch his films you
understand what the term feel good movie
means i mean they're like these gigantic
spectacles that make you completely
forget about your troubles whatever they
are
um
i really recommend one called gold
diggers of 1933 because it's one of the
few dance movies with a plot that you
can actually follow that is enjoyable
usually that
you know the plots are forgettable
they're just a way to get you to the
next dance number
uh the gang's all here is also an
amazing one that's in technicolor
the earlier ones are in black and white
he i don't know if he pioneered this but
he was known for
using huge numbers of dancers on
gigantic stages and shooting them from
all angles so often from above creating
these uh really interesting geometric
formations that moved in and out of each
other
he did a lot of work in the water with
mr williams
so
it makes sense that he shows up in this
particular book because this is a book
about mass trauma and
masses of bodies experiencing trauma
there are there are frequent images of
mass graves in this book but also
the 20th century was a time visually
where there are so many images of
columns of people
uh columns of refugees columns of
soldiers piles of of dead bodies
huge numbers of dancers on a massive
stage
the number of people is monumental in a
single image
so
one of my writing techniques is that i i
keep a pile of note cards and i just
write single beats or ideas on them i
learned this from my partner tom hart
who this is i'm sure a lot of writers do
this though it's a really great thing to
do because then you won't forget
anything and that is how
i
stumbled on a note i had written myself
a couple of years prior that just said
buzzfeed berkeley death scene
i think i wrote that note to myself in
2017 and i found it in 2019 and i
thought thank you 2017 leela
because here it is so i i deliberately
i'm not showing you what happens right
before this scene
but i will tell you
this is an ss officer who's been hanged
in
in the camp yard after the allies have
have entered the camp
this was a thing that happened
occasionally where they would let the
prisoners have at it with the guards
and when he gets to the other side
all of his his former
people he's killed mass in a big dance
number and take him apart and sing a
little song
and there's also also a little oscar
schlemmer tribute in here who is a
bauhaus artist i'm extremely fond of
um
i recommend him a lot
these are the random pages from here
that i wanted to show you
um in this book i'm very obsessed with
the dream state and the death state
and i was thinking a lot about what what
happens to people's subconscious at a
time of mass trauma
and what happens in places where a mass
trauma is underway or has just occurred
i thought of all of this i pitched this
book in 2016.
i i i sold it in june 2016.
then trump became president and
while you know so i'm working on a book
about a fascist time period
while all of this is happening in my own
country
and they're starting to be
highly visible
signs of neo-nazi activity in the street
and
all sorts of
really nasty stuff happening and i i
i remember having the thought that this
is the only thing i can think of as
activism right now this is the only
thing i can do
um
slow very slow-moving activism
not sure it's activism actually
and then while i'm
in the final stretch of doing this the
pandemic started so
i here here we are experiencing
multiple rolling mass traumas global
pandemic
climate change
uh that feels
it feels like no one in power wants to
address
most of the mass traumas that we are
experiencing now as a species
so here i am working on this thinking
this couldn't be more
appropriate for the time
basically what i'm doing here is
shouldering my little corner of
humanity's coffin um
but on that note
let's look at some wrestlers
[Laughter]
i have a dance and martial arts
background and i really like drawing
people
in motion uh it's it's really
it's really fun for me i assume this is
still sharing yeah um
but i i didn't really think about
wrestling very much until i i did a
record cover for a band called the
mountain goats that was wrestling themed
and that had me drawing wrestlers all
the time and i didn't want to stop i
really like drawing sweaty bodies in
space
so this is an early excerpt of this book
that ran in the believer
and boy i had fun drawing this and
drawing these crowd scenes
um
i think you can kind of tell from the
way that i draw wrestling though that
i'm i don't have a wrestling background
i have a martial arts background
i was trying
um
so
what's happening here is uh this this
poor
jewish refugee wrestler is being
mistaken as a german
and having a little visitation from her
dead mother
as i said i'm extremely obsessed with
the dream state and depicting it
that is a moving target it's hard to
write a good dream sequence
and i'm not sure this is really a dream
either it's not really a dream
the final excerpt of this that i will
show is
this also ran in the believer
this is the the navy yard character
reading uh passage from the
playful octates to her lover i want to
talk a little bit about why falacity is
because i want to give credit to the
person who
turned me on to that play with it's a
guy named brian dories who founded an
organization called theater of war which
i
cannot recommend enough
theater of war performs uh classical
greek dramas for traumatized populations
often with the people from those
those communities so i think they
started out doing it with military
veterans
velocities is i
think the play they started with um it's
a play about a wounded soldier
and in this particular scene her lover
is a world war one veteran who lost his
leg and she's reading this this scene
from
from this play in which this this
soldier has a leg injury
a catastrophic leg injury
and sneaking back to her apartment
all right so i promised to talk a little
bit about
materiality and scanning
in this dream sequence which is very
definitely a dream sequence i used
in these trees
i i
painted these in black ink with a lot of
water wash and then i dripped from kind
of a
12 inches above it
uh iridescent liquid acrylic ink into
the wet black ink and what happened was
really interesting and hard to see
unless you oops unless you zoom in
um
darn it how do i move this
down
it's all right i you know i think yeah
if you can scroll up in the image
without
accidentally scrolling up in the
slideshow
yeah just bring this down
if you could bring the whole thing down
yeah that's great thank you
uh you can kind of see what happened the
the liquid acrylic ink and the wet black
sumi ink kind of interacted with each
other and created a crackle texture that
the light from the scanner bounced off
of
in a way that i really love
so there's things you can't see in the
print or in the scan but but then there
are things that happen that are not
predictable that you can
um
continuing into her dream
and smoke break at the brooklyn navy
yard
and then we move into his dream
about a victory garden full of severed
limbs
and some
light reading for insomnia
to end the visual part of the
presentation
so this is what i'm working on now and
i'm almost finished with it although i
feel like i've been saying that for a
long time
i swear i really am almost finished with
this book
uh so now would be a great time to open
it up to discussion
right um first of all
um let's open up the question um
and
you i mean
do you see it as a gaining or a loss
when when prints are digitized and if so
what is gained what is lost
and and how do you negotiate that
relationship when you're making
that's a great question um
i have to not think about it too hard
when i'm making it or at least not think
about it as a loss
so what i think about it instead is um
for people who can see the original
they get uh to have a kind of an
experience that that people who can't
um won't have unfortunately and i i wish
i could share that with everybody but
when you go into making comics you
you're making an agreement with yourself
that
all the work you're doing is mostly
going to be disseminated
on a mass scale or you know mass scale
meaning you know a print run of 300 or 3
000 or
30 000 not really huge but
that most people will see a reproduction
of your work
uh so actually most of the time
for most of my career i was thinking of
uh working towards reproduction and what
so so what feels like a gain really to
me a gift is uh working without worrying
about that now
so instead of just working in ink and
thinking about it as like okay this is
black and white it's very easy to
to reduce down and print
now i'm not thinking about it at all and
maybe this will be a nightmare for the
production department of my publisher i
hope not i don't want to give them
nightmares but
but when i'm thinking about the
materiality
when i'm working with it
it's
it's so rich and it's creating so much
of the narrative
i want to say the pigments themselves
in their textures and their colors
when they're wet when they're dry are
part of the story
the
the controlled chaos of working with
watercolor is part of the story itself
so
because that is that's
because that's the point at which the
portal opens
where i have access to the other side
whatever that is and
and uh i'm a bit of a closet mystic
you
have
to
just bear with me there uh that's that's
where all the good stuff is i i don't
worry about what might be sacrificed uh
in the
digital or print production but i have
been pleasantly surprised
because sometimes things come out in
really interesting ways like um
when the believer printed these pieces
they looked gorgeous on paper
i think part of that is their production
standards are really high
uh but it just it surprised me how good
it looked even flattened down to a print
um
you were talking earlier about the movie
from 1975 that depicts kind of human
chaos and
moral
um
uh
i don't know how to put it just sort of
the messiness i guess of
everything that world war ii represents
and so you talked about how
you
strive to kind of capture that messiness
in your own work and i'm wondering how
you negotiate
capturing messiness and
chaos but also having structure and um
control
in your narrative i love that
um
i mean the first answer i want to give
is
i i hope i have structured my narrative
i'm a little concerned about that in
this book actually
um
writing a plot is the hardest thing
i think for me i don't know maybe there
are people who are really really good at
it and that's their favorite thing but i
think for i want to say a lot of writers
i know that's that's the hard part is
um marshalling ideas into a structure
even if it's not necessarily a story
about something vast and chaotic um
although really i think any human
subject is vast and chaotic like even
the most interior
personal novel you know
um
it helps to
absorb really good film storytelling i
have found to to learn
kind of structural
um
tricks and not tricks that's the wrong
word but learn how to how to structure
certain kinds of stories
um
i
love prose novels absolutely love them
but i like to say that when i read them
i'm kind of like an ant crawling on a
beautiful sculpture i don't really know
what i'm what i'm seeing
so
for me film storytelling uh is really
close to comic storytelling it's not
exact but really good film and very good
episodic uh writing for television like
something like dead wood you know or the
wire like mad men like the really really
high end
another really good one that's been a
big
influence on me is russian doll natasha
leone's
netflix series is amazing
um there's some very serious writing and
very very interesting interplay of
interior exterior
um real surreal
in
in a lot of that storytelling
and very human
um
so what i look for before any kind of
structure and
is i i look for human experience and i
let that guide me into the structure
um
i don't know if this is relevant to your
question at all but one of the things
that i'm trying to do and and something
that i'm attracted to in in a lot of
other people's work too is
to take time periods that have been
turned into a kind of mythology
which again can be very easily tidied up
and presented in a packaged nice way
and
open them up and find
the really messy human stories inside of
them
now if you think about any
any film about
or novel about a historical time period
right um
i'm
i'm i'm veering into a dangerous
direction here of subjectivity where i'm
going to tell you the movies i don't
like
to do this um but heck i'll i'll go out
on that limb i'll say like schindler's
list is a really good example of
way too tidy i called that one auschwitz
for [ __ ]
um
it's so clean and so packaged and so
neat and everyone is so happy at the end
even even the ways that are that it
depicts um trauma and bad things
happening it's very sanctioned right so
where's the mess where's the humanity
um
to bring it back to your question
when when i hook into those really human
stories and those really messy
um human dramas that's where the
structure begins to suggest itself
because that's the trajectory of a
character that's what the structure has
to be built around
that i struggle with structure
completely
part of this also is uh i tend to write
uh in a fragmentary way so i write my
stories kind of all over the place i
don't write from from the beginning to
the end and i finally realized why
i don't know if i'm making an excuse or
if this is the real reason but i trained
initially as a painter and when you
train as a painter you're trained to
work all over the canvas
all at once
so that's kind of how i write and i have
to say i don't think that serves a
linear narrative very well
luckily this current book is not so
linear but
hopefully the next one will be does that
approach your question at all yeah oh
good okay
we have a couple that have come in from
the chat yeah so i'm just going to read
those to you
from tom hart
oh hi
does it work can you pay for other
materials to process trauma as opposed
to working digitally or using your media
what an awesome question i love that
question um
yes it does
uh but i would say that's a really
subjective answer for me it does
for you it might not so for another
person working digitally might be the
exact key that they need to get past
whatever their inner resistance is to
making an image
and and take them exactly where they
need to go
uh that that might be the tool um i
don't want to be dogmatic about um
physical materials versus digital
materials
but i will say that from my own
experience um
the tactility and the physicality of
materials brings me to that place where
i'm i'm facing whatever it is i'm
working with
i will come back a little bit to my day
at the harvard art museum today
there was a bit of wall text about
primitivism after the war in i in
germany uh actually i think it was a
carl apple painting he was dutch but i
think he might have been working in
germany i'm not sure
um
talking about a movement of artists who
used materials in a
as the wall text coded i'm going to
paraphrase
frenzied frenetic uh primitive style
uh so this is a painting with a lot of
impasto and hard marks and and you can
tell it was done with a lot of um speed
and intensity and
the wall text
goes on to say this is a reaction to the
destruction and and of world war ii and
and the absolute horror
at
the violation of humanity now that's
that's my words
i understand this
uh
and this is kind of what i'm getting at
when i talk about the physicality of
materials sometimes you're working in a
way
where it's it's you and your body
um
bashing against the materials or using
them as an extension of your body
right
um an analogy to this would be certain
kinds of music too i remember when i was
in my early 20s thinking i want i want
to hear
musicians playing their instruments so
hard that it's like they're breaking
like i don't understand how you can play
a guitar in a certain kind of mood
without tearing the strings in half
now
this gets refined
we refine ourselves away from that
working working in comics and especially
in the kind of comics i'm doing
i i didn't talk about miniaturist
painting but that's also been a really
big influence on me and both
medieval european and and persian
miniature and
it's like an extreme obsessive control
with tiny little brushes
and and very small areas of paint very
small passages within the painting
[Music]
but within that there are these micro
realms of chaos and and
portals of of emotion that open
uh so yes
to answer your question
but again i want to say for somebody
else the answer may be the opposite of
the answer may be that uh working in
procreate or another digital uh medium
might be exactly the thing that takes
them to that that emotional state that
they need to tell their story
[Music]
all right just a second
all right so lily m asks
you don't write superhero comic books do
you have feelings on the inherent
jewishness of them that influence you at
all
do you think that it's trying to be
covered up somewhat at the moment as
well
um that's a great question but i think
i'm not the person to answer it because
i have never read a superhero comic um
i
will say i i'm aware of the
uh of how many jews created the
superhero comics
world
and i'm a huge jack kirby fan for other
reasons because the guy was an absolute
maniac of an inker
drawer
i teach his story street code in my
classes sometimes just because it's an
incredible piece of our art
and i love will eisner dearly but i
haven't actually read spirit i've read
his more autobiographical stories
his bronx stories
i would like to put the question back to
you questioner um
is it being covered up how i'm so
curious about that
i wonder if they would be willing to
address that in their comments
yeah
anything else um
anybody else
i'm just going to quickly interject for
anyone who is both numerically curious
it is mind-blowingly rude stuff yes
personally footlight parade is the most
kind of
approachable gateway
um in terms of like it actually have a
little more story not just excuses
yes he's amazing it's pre-code which we
all know about from our class right so
it's like
extra dirty
and it has by a waterfall
which is a completely
bonkers art deco water dance insanity is
this bonkers like are we underwater
are we on drugs
[Laughter]
but also um
thinking about these moving bodies as a
fascist aesthetic that
might if you hadn't seen the film seem
like that's a strange leap and it's a
very interesting leap and move moment
movement but when you see it you're like
oh yeah they're marching there there are
goose stepping scenes in buzzfeed
berkeley films there is this kind of
management of mass management of bodies
that at certain moments will make you
think of lenny reid michelle's
management of bodies i wanna sorry go
ahead no that's it
i wanna say something about that so i i
just wanna say the fascists did not
invent that kind of imagery there i
think
i i'm not gonna
i'm gonna talk out of out of school
about history because i
i don't know actually who invented it
but i i think the early 20th century is
full of of propagandistic imagery like
that right um
although some of the futurists were
fascists
but there's a really interesting the
closing number of busby berkeley's gold
diggers of 1933 is a complete mood
change so this this particular film
is goofy it's kind of a hey kids let's
put on a show
uh plot it's said
made and set during the depression and
it's basically people trying to get a
book to eat by putting on a show
and there's all it's also pre-code and
there's also a really fabulously dirty
filthy number uh that ends with a guy
opening up a woman's metal outfit with a
can opener it's wild
the honeymoon hotel i think is that i
can't remember which one that's in the
can opener to get into this woman's oh
is that in honeymoon hotel also uh the
one the number i'm thinking of is um
is patton in the park
but then there's this total mood shift
at the end uh there's a song called uh
remember my forgotten man and
it ends in this art deco kind of
agit prop
imagery
but there's also there's imagery of
there's all of these men marching off to
war in these clean uniforms and coming
back ragged and bloody and carrying
their comrades on stretchers their heads
are bandaged there's a whole bunch of
dancers on a on a bread line passing one
cigarette down the line
and then there's like these recreations
of dorothea lang dust bowl photos in
this dance number
it's wild to see it
um
i think it's a really interesting point
though to bring up the fascist use of
mass bodies
i think there's a very
short distance between anti-fascist art
and fascist art
and i i think that the the commonality
is
well i don't wanna i don't wanna say
that commonality is only propaganda
because
so so much of the modernist art that the
fascists hated
uh was was not propagandistic at all it
had nothing to do with politics in so
many cases
but
it was telling the truth about human
bodies in war and starvation
which was not
agreeable to fascists at all they only
wanted
very able very strong very well fed
bodies
it's worth looking at the degenerate art
exhibition and then at the counter
exhibition that the nazis mounted
of incredibly boring state-approved
fascist art
that's a subject i'm really interested
in in talking and learning more about
um thank you do we have more uh online
yeah i have a question for mauricio oh
excellent so from maurice ferdeiro what
are your thoughts on transgressions and
passages of time
does the passage of time impact the
narrative
of transgressive comics
well that's a really good question um
i'm trying to think of comics that i
think of as transgressive i mean i guess
since i was talking about phoebe um
i want to say i'm not sure it does
impact
it's it's
i don't think it blunts the impact of
those comics
you know it'd be really interesting it
would be really interesting if there was
a younger cartoonist here
to counter me
and argue with me about this or just
talk about what younger cartoonists are
doing now because i have my own
observations about
certain trends that i see in comics but
kind of the curse of the mid-career
artist is that you don't really have
time to read a lot of other people's
work because you're too busy doing your
own
also being a mid-career artist means
doing a lot of paperwork it turns out
so i feel i haven't read enough of
of what's out there now in the last
decade or so
but i feel like there's a lot less
grotesquery in comics than there used to
be
i this is totally subjective and i could
be completely wrong
but i wonder if
um
younger cartoonists coming up today
might look at something like
a nightmare on polk street that phoebe
lechner story or renee french's work
from the 90s or even julie dusay's
comics and think like ew this is gross
or i don't want to see that or that
that's really like
yeah i suspect maybe not actually but
mauricio i wish you were here to
actually
talk about this in person and
and give your own thoughts on that
because i think that's a really
interesting question
i think
i think what has changed over time is
the way that certain kinds of um
edgelordy transgressive behavior uh has
been
like whether it's approved of in the
culture or not i i so i'll go outside of
comics for a second here
um
i follow steve albini on twitter and he
posted this great
thread steve albini for those who don't
know is a musician and record producer
kind of iconic recording engineer but he
also was an iconic musician and in the
80s he was in a band called big black
who were very deliberately transgressive
but also he was
sort of a professional jerk in that band
i i love them and i love his writing
when you read his writing from that time
period you can see him like really
trying to push people's buttons in this
way that was really permissible in the
culture at the time especially from
white guys
and so
the the
the newer way of looking at this stuff
now to say you know we don't we don't
really want to give everybody a pass
anymore that's really good but he posted
this thing on twitter about that exactly
saying
look you can't you can't bust me on my
past i know i know a lot of what i said
and did was wrong i'm paraphrasing
really poorly you should find the thread
yourself he said it much better than i
could he was like you know good luck
trying to
trying to shame me i've already publicly
outed myself as in in all of these ways
you know and then he sort of talked a
little bit more about how things have
changed and how that's better it was
really interesting
as for comics
i want blood i want to see blood on the
walls
metaphorically speaking i want i want
people to make
work that is hard to look at i think
that's kind of what comics are for
that's my little teeny soapbox that i'm
ranting on
um
but i'm also fine if people don't
i'm not sure how to answer the time part
of this question
so do you associate mess with with this
this paradigm are you saying like you
want more mess and therefore being messy
is to have more because
chaos and mess don't always
have to be aligned there's a lot of
chaos in minimalism there's a lot of
chaos and yeah the negative in removal
and not just presences chaos and absence
as well
so like how do you how are you defining
this and and
this erratic mess as opposed to a clean
mess
so erratic is actually not a value of
mine personally interesting um
i'm actually extremely controlled in my
work
but
the original your the first thing you
said in your question um no i don't
think i'm defining it as only mess and
actually you know when i i'm really
careful about what i say in public about
what i want comics to be because for one
thing who the hell am i i'm just one
person what i think really doesn't
matter outside of the scope of my own
work
i want people to make comics and tell
their story in whatever way works for
them
so i guess i'm just expressing a taste
that i want to see
intensity and i think that might be a
better word
um
when i talk about mess
sometimes i'm talking about materials or
the physical method of drawing but
sometimes i'm talking about storytelling
or i mean the
uh
not the structure i don't want the
structure to be messy
the um
the
humanity i think what i'm really arguing
for more than mess is truth though and
and the truth about people is that we're
messy
although as you know as i'm saying all
this i'm realizing like
there's only so far out on that on this
limb this particular limb i can go right
i also love really clean controlled art
and i love
i love minimalism and maximalism both
yeah is this addressing your question at
all it's not a question it's just more
i'm just curious because i'm negotiating
it all the time
right and so i'm curious about you um no
i'm not
well what i'm curious about is what um
how are you negotiating these these
factors
um
oh god guys i wasn't prepared
i don't know i mean in my own maybe i
guess daily life there's no artistic
element to it just you know mess as it's
represented as opposed to mess as it's
felt or or it is like messes and
ontology versus mess as a representation
right
can sometimes
be
in the form of a single line right or
like
it can be in and especially in kind of
socio-political environments where where
intensity isn't necessarily allowed
then how does cleanliness become a form
of like radicalization or like like an
act of radical politics or radical
revolution you know so
and that's my own sociocultural
background that i come from bring so i'm
bringing a little bit of like nuance to
that the idea of mess that i've seen
sometimes in kind of western are just
about contemporary i love this i'm so
curious about this like
i mean i'm a novice at that that's a
really interesting
bunch of stuff that you just brought up
i don't know
um and i i would say i also
when i talk about messiness i think i'm
also coming from a teaching perspective
where i for a long time i taught
non-majors in an illustration class and
in a comics class and
most of the time i was trying to get
them comfortable with
uh making mistakes and getting dirty and
just kind of basic like
dealing with materials that you can't
predict and can't always control and
just letting relinquishing some control
letting things be
um like
you know
draw even though you don't know how to
draw get
charcoal on your fingers it's okay kind
of basic stuff that i think a lot of us
get through early on but if you don't
have any art training and you're
you know 22 years old and you're a
journalism major or an engineering major
and you come into an art class sometimes
you need a little permission to just
make a mess so kind of like on a really
basic level right
um
i like elements of of chaos that are
marshaled into very clean parameters in
in music and in art as well like
very intense guitar feedback with a very
very structured uh rhythm section for
example um
i'm really intrigued by your question
about
when does cleanliness become an act of
radicalism
that's where i feel like wow i
i do not know
um i think i'm very privileged in that
i'm i i live in a world where i mostly
am alone and not having to deal with
um
expectations that i'm always very
controlled and clean in my presentation
you know
that's
so provocative i just want to interject
that you know
those in the room or away you know who
are not um artists but are creating in
other ways like as writers like people
about to write a thesis
people writing in general um
uh you know i think some of these issues
about how the process works can
be applied to a writer's
a non-painting writer as well as it were
as it were or non-conference writer uh
and you know i was thinking about three
points in particular one was this last
one about making mistakes and messiness
and cleanliness and just like writing
writing writing knowing that like ninety
percent of it's going to go
and that the ten percent
you know this is it right is the magic
or it's the best part of it right
copying from your favorite painter as a
strategy uh
in parallel copying it from your
favorite writer right you're not
plagiarizing but like how do i use this
style i love this and just experimenting
and playing with that and then possibly
most importantly my own perspective and
people might you know got twenty two
three things that everyone might have
their own thing that they think this was
useful but from my own perspective the
uh question you asked really early on
what are you putting in your nebula as
you were i thought was just beautiful
because you know that's where you know
if you're reading stuff that you're
thinking i don't like the style or the
argument or the method or the sources
and like if that's all you're reading
like it's not going to get you in the
right frame or mind to do your own work
right and it's having that work
in the net you know even if it's not
saying media history media theory right
but you're just reading the right
tony morrison novel that gets you
thinking about language and
and
forging
a work that that can help you you know
just so so just keep thinking about your
network
yeah what are you feeding yourself with
you know what are you what what's in
your diet i guess is another way of
putting it
your
some of what you brought up made me
think of um
something i put in my notes
a question
that i also don't think is answered
which is where do you put your
deadliness
and you can apply that to anywhere in
your work in your daily life in
environments where you are expected to
be controlled
um where do where do you put
whatever you define as as
deadliness
another thing you made me think of was a
reaction i had to a lot of the work that
i saw today at the art museum
there's an incredible photography
exhibition
um at the harvard art museum right now
called devour the land
that's i i really recommend it but i
recommend going with a strong stomach um
it's all photographs of
the impact of war and war industries on
america on environments on the land on
humans on communities
so there's a lot of
historical photographs from the post-war
period but also a lot of stuff about
environmental racism that's more recent
a lot of it
some of it not so recent
and it made me think about
the thing i've been wrestling with a lot
lately too
which is just
the the impossibility of comprehending
most most of what happens in this world
okay so this may be getting close to
what i call my two watt light bulb which
is um when i realized something
that's been obvious to most people for a
long time there it is a little too high
light bulb
but i think it's always worth
remembering um i think we we feel huge
to ourselves and we feel like we're
supposed to understand things we're
supposed to be able to comprehend things
and process information and synthesize
it and
spit out some kind of
product or processing response to it
right
as an artist i increasingly feel
completely incapable of that
and that all i can do is document
certain kinds of trauma that are
sometimes really personal and sometimes
they're
personal ways of talking about something
that's more collective
and i also increasingly feel
that i'm incapable of understanding
other
other kinds of group trauma i try to
understand it on a
on a humanity wide scale but i i have to
question whether that's the right thing
to do you know because
am i am i universalizing
my own community's experience
and and therefore missing other other
communities experiences
uh does that make sense
[Laughter]
the nature or the source of
artistic growth at that point oh boy
you know people early on they still have
all of their influences that
other artists or writers that did love
that had some kind of meaning for them
early on from the beach
absorbed
into their own aesthetic
um but
you're talking about in a career you're
no longer
as often
engaging with
quite the opposite mid-career is when
all the good stuff starts to happen
because up to then
you know
well again i don't want to universalize
my own experience but i think i don't
think there's anything particularly
special or unique about me so i'll say
probably common experience for a lot of
people in in your 20s you're kind of a
wreck um
and just trying to figure stuff out and
getting through school trying to figure
out your career path
uh in your 30s you're maybe you're
hustling a lot maybe you're starting a
family maybe not maybe you're you're
just
starting significant partnerships
um in my case i was working as an
illustrator and i was completely i had
parts of myself as an artist completely
locked away inaccessible thinking i
would never
be the artist i thought i was going to
be when i was younger because i had
chosen this path of kind of
lesser resistance
and yes i was making comics but i felt
like i was just
never touching that source of power
where
where is
i don't know how to get to that thing i
really want to do and that the
the kind of power that i want to have in
my storytelling and in my visual art
uh and the kind of illustration work i
was doing i knew i wasn't a great
illustrator and i knew that you know it
was just kind of workmanlike and
it didn't really feel like me
um
it started to kind of break open a
little the first time i heard a nico
case album
and when i heard her music i thought
this is the kind of she's in touch with
something that i i want to
be too she's she's got her finger in
some kind of electrical socket that
that's
really intense
a few other things also when i i there
was a huge
retrospective of the south african
artist william kentridge at at moma
right before i left new york city and
that was also a kind of moment of being
broken open like this
this is really
this is what i'm saying this is what
it's supposed to be
uh around the same time there was a
carol walker retrospective too and that
had a similar effect even more that was
extremely humbling
to see her work
so for me i didn't become the artist
that even start to become the artist i
really thought i was going to be and
really could be until i was in my 40s
uh so the the thing that happens
oh god again i don't want to say like
okay this is what's gonna happen to
everybody
but again i think it's a sort of common
experience you get to a point in your
life where you have enough accumulated
experience and wisdom
that you can turn around and share it
with people coming up behind you but
then also you have
all of this this bank of experience and
training and and
the hard knocks to draw on in your life
then that's when the real power comes if
you if you can find a way to access it
because that's that's when you have
that right balance of all of the
messiness of your life and all of the
clean parameters of your discipline
to filter it through right and it
becomes this very focused laser beam
um i would love to hear somebody else's
description of this this is just mine
but
uh the curse of the mid-career artist is
really just that you don't necessarily
have time to read other people's books
but that does not mean you don't have
time to engage with art for me it's
meant
reopening my engagement with the rest of
of art that's being made and i almost
said the art world but i want to make a
distinction when i say that i'm not
talking about
um the art world that we often disparage
that's art dealers and the money part of
the art world i mean the world of people
making things
i i really tried to run away from it
because art school can be kind of a
scarring experience
um i tried to run away from it into
illustration and comics and coming back
to it has been really healing
uh and you start to engage in a crop
well for me i started to engage in a
really cross-disciplinary way with a lot
of other art forms too that i had either
locked away from myself
or or that i had never even come close
to before
and that's that's when the interesting
stuff started to happen so i'm really
it's not really a curse you know that's
just it just means i don't have time to
follow the trends in comics and that's
fine like
i was listening to an interview with one
of my favorite musicians blitzabargeld
who is in his early 60s now and
there's almost nobody more interesting
or disciplined or in in touch with
very very wild creative power than him
but in this interview he said i'm out of
touch i'm really out of touch with
what's happening in music and that's
fine he was talking about having a
school-age daughter how she's really
into billy eilish and he's like yeah you
know she she listens to all this pop
music that i i just there's no possible
way i could follow it that's kind of a
pleasure of getting older too it's like
oh you know
i'll i'll i'll let the kids have that
and i'm i'm over here doing something
else
it's cool
um the the other thing about being a
mid-career artist is just that you're
applying for a lot of grants and a lot
of residencies and
it is amazing how much time is spent on
administrative work
do you have any more questions
uh so you mentioned earlier that the
story changes like when they're like the
pigments are in water there's like it's
part of the story and then when it dries
it's also part of the story uh
i'm wondering
if every time
the
painting change
do you think the story is changing
and also i'm wondering whether
like like what story are you talking
about like
from what i understood it's about the
story of the comic but i'm wondering
more like whether it's the story
your relation
with your art like what is changing or
evolving
in this you know like when it's
when you're experimenting with the water
and you're like letting the watercolor
like emerge right it's one story and
then
but it's your is it like your connection
with
your painting with your comic
or
it's both yeah it's very much my own
connection with it
and it's what's happening in the
narrative it's also allowing a door to
open
for unconscious and subconscious stuff
to come out
the unplanned the surprising and some of
that stuff is physical like oh i didn't
expect the ink to go that direction and
then dry like that and then some of it
is narrative like oh
wow i didn't realize that i was actually
you know here i have i have characters
saying
these particular words having this
particular conversation but then there's
these colors things happening that are
kind of telling
it's a nonverbal signal under the verbal
part of the narrative
that can either
it's not so clean and binary as it's
either
reinforcing the narrative or or
countering it it's not quite that simple
uh but it's part of the story that makes
sense
i want to say also i had really intense
color theory training i had the like the
really standard bauhaus color theory
pedagogy and the way that i like to
describe that is
it's like they
they put you under for three months and
then they snap their fingers and you
wake up and you can mix any color
like put anything in front of me and i
can mix it and i don't know how i got
there except that it involved cutting a
lot of color aid which is a really
irritating substance
but
something that i did in the period
between the 2020 election and
the inauguration
um was i i was so
i was in this like physiological panic
state that i was starting to worry about
like i'm worried about the future of my
my physical health like i'm going to
have like heart problems or neurological
problems from the amount of stress that
i'm under right now the amount of threat
that i feel
so
at you know imminent fascism
so
in order to kind of build a little
barrier around my intellect at the very
least i
i had a ritual for a while where every
night at the end of my work day i would
paint all day and then i would
uh take
it's book of color theory italian was
one of the bauhaus color theory teachers
and
i would read two pages from it every
night
and it was so restorative even though
some of it i couldn't understand some of
it was was above me like i'm just too
dense for this and some of it was like
poetry poetry of color talking about
color
um
i feel as i was reading it i felt like
okay this now i kind of i understand the
more
uh theoretical and and kind of
existential aspects of this
thing i was trained so hard in
that comes out in my work uh so when i'm
in that state of experimenting i'm
drawing on those uh that training and
those experiences without knowing i'm
doing it and really interesting stuff
happens because of that
does that make sense
we're right up on time do we have any
other questions online that we need to
there might be a quick one
uh so i think that there are multiple
definitions to that lily thank you for
asking
that's a good thing to clarify
um
sometimes that deadliness is in your own
responses and reactions to the world
to
whatever it is that really pisses you
off or hurts you or that fascinates you
um
where do you put
those reactions where do those impulses
go right
um
for me
it takes the form of um
i want to exhibit some sometimes i well
let me go back i'm very fascinated with
the line between beauty and brutality
so i want to explore that line a lot i
want to play on that line kind of like
one foot on each side
see where where my weight is on on
either side of that line
um
and i want to share that with people so
that's where i put my deadliness like i
i wanna sometimes i i wanna
i want something that's pointy not to
hurt people with but to give people a
sense of solidarity
like
i i have reacted to this thing too
does that make sense
so where do you put that in your in
yourself in your own work where do you
where do you i guess uh like maybe a
another way to put it would be where do
you focus your rage
but i don't want to make it sound like
everything is about rage if it's not
um but but that's just one way of
expressing it
how do you make something out of
out of difficulty difficult experiences
personal or collective
how do you work with what is difficult
thank you so much i think we will end on
that note
thank you for having me and thank you
for your amazing questions and
discussion points